let me tell you about my day so far no
also narration oh yeah and I got digits
from this polish chicken real I don't
know what her being polish has anything
to do with this but the point is you got
a chick's phone number what a life and
then I jumped back for the final quarter
of the NBA Finals courtside of course
and all that was before lunch you know
because they play the NBA Finals in the
morning now everyone's schedule is wake
up shower breakfast NBA Finals then
lunch also you jumped in to courtside
seats at the NBA Finals in the final
quarter I can't even begin to scold you
properly for all the common decency you
just violated there did you take
someone's seat you decided to do this in
the fourth quarter nobody saw you also I
like how this asshole brought this
goddamn surfboard with him during this
jumping to the top of the Sphinx for
some reason you know to impress the
other dipface douche-nozzles like
himself once I was a normal person a
chump just like you hey I'm not a chump
I make youtube videos that are overly
nitpicky for the sake of calm I have a
chum partner Milly instantly gets uncool
points for spelling Prague incorrectly
that's not a typo that's a right Oh
Oh raro picked it up 40 yards Selma
missing cuz that's what I do I go yard
sailing in Plymouth with my gammy every
weekend and when I see things that made
me think of girls I'm stalking who think
I'm a weirdo I buy that shit for them
then I give it to them at school in a
newspaper I want to make out why is this
white bully constantly calling this
white outcast kid rice bowl how is that
an insult rice bowls are being delicious
see I have this rule that goes like this
he never walk out on a frozen body of
water for any reason and if rice bowl
had followed this rule he'd be dry right
now already and humiliated but drop
David's miraculous first jump manages to
happen in the aisle of a busy library
and nobody sees it and that's how it
happened the first time
you mean catching pneumonia home sweet
home mom left when I was five as for dad
well let's just say he wasn't much woman
he roland emmerich film teleport only on
the second time David teleporter does he
become amazed that he teleported the
first time you can chalk that up to some
weird thing that happens second time now
we wonder what's going on ironic library
posters David jump to the library the
first time when the school went out for
the day then he walked home and
incredibly didn't die of hypothermia
during what must have been a two-hour
walk because once he jumps back to the
library they already got the yellow tape
up then closed the building for the day
and no one's here
tap on the window sure let me go explore
that outside in the cold in my pajamas
and then just happen to find the snow
globe this asshole David left for me on
a swing in the middle of the pin yard
good thing I'm dumb and curious and have
alligator blood I wanted to tell her
everything how about something I figured
it was time to move on because you
discovered your power or the abuse of
debt over the girl you have a crush on
honestly not sure why you so blindly
decided to move up whatever you can
teleport does it matter where you go or
where you are at any given moment even
though I can teleport I took the bus the
slowest fucking mass transit system in
America and so there I was I had a
million questions like how does this
thing work it took me the entire bus
ride from Michigan to start coming up
with those questions I didn't even try
to find an open field somewhere to see
if I could practice this new power I
said let's just go to New York City and
figure it out I'm handing out wings this
nugget decides let's try my power in
central fucking Park first man at least
the kids from Chronicle used the
backyard in the beginning I was 15
come on what would you have done at 15
not robbed a bank
I probably opt myself into a
cheerleading practice or onto the
pitcher's mound at Yankee Stadium I
would not have immediately left a grand
theft you are unique in that aspect you
big troublemaker is there a bathroom for
customers yes there is and it's really
far away from here and I'm the only
entrance cart but let me lead you to it
personally for some reason it goes right
by the safe and everything I understand
the safe was open earlier but not very
long how could David visualize jumping
inside this safe when he only caught a
tiny glimpse of it
yeah he's 15 and stupid but why would he
steal a box of coins like three bills
from any stack of bills he steals or
worth more than an entire box of any
kind of coins this hairstyle he went
from I want to escape which be home to I
want to steal all the time in about two
months time also Pepsi yo also he stole
something that says police on it and
which appears to be a bike or motorcycle
his name should be tries to get caught
with a fist this is how the movie
decides to age up its main character a
literal cut from age 15 to age what is
this maybe 22 tops
tell me again why the same actor
couldn't play both roles like some
incredible dickhead David transports in
a frivolous manner throughout his
apartment in its super lazy fashion
house this guy is leg muscles not
atrophied already from severe under use
this is completely unnecessary but thank
God for this movie's plot Billy Elliot
is here to see this so that the movie
can continue movie also he randomly
showed up to London for no good reason
and just happens to be at the same bar
another rare teleporter is in that's bad
that's coincidence defined but it's even
worse that our hero teleports inside the
bar
from the door to the bar thereby
exposing himself to detection in the
first place it's like four feet asshole
exactly how lazy do you have to be
teleporting distances this small this
guy has all the money in the world but
he still feels the need to steal some I
mean at least show him leaving a couple
hundred bucks behind before showing him
surfing his ass off at the ocean this is
a usual thing for David to jump onto the
Sphinx with the surfboard lawn chair CD
player and fast food he's probably
dripping ketchup and mustard all over
the Sphinx his head and nobody ever sees
him and yes the line shot reveals that
you would indeed have been easily seen
by a native or tourist I mean somebody
call Egypt on this dude this is
apparently another jumper who just got
caught by Samuel Jackson for the xxx
program that trains Jedi in the ways of
the Avengers also the beginning of the
scene shows this guy in transporting
through the trees to get away from the
NSA people but why didn't he just
transport somewhere that's not this
place all places of course these jumper
hunting assholes have a religious reason
because of course they do
tell you when we need that umbrella wait
a fucking second are you telling me that
somehow all the things David just did in
the last four minutes were all on the
same day he transported to London where
Big Ben was kind enough to tell us it
was 8:30 London time which is 3:30 in
New York City he picked up the hot chick
at the bar and he tried to go surfing in
Martha's Vineyard but then these helpful
dudes told him that Fiji was the place
to go so he went there and shortly after
he wiped out he went to diese
this is where they hooked up Giza is
seven hours ahead in New York and he was
there in broad daylight even giving the
benefit of the doubt that all his
activities took 8 or 9 hours and he was
in Giza in the morning he would not have
been able to get back to New York during
any kind of hours where the apartment
Lobby was still busy and this guy was
still working eight years we've been
looking for you
that's how terrible we are at our jobs
discount mace windu teaches Anakin a
lesson David's father has David's old
room chained up because reasons also
we're supposed to somehow believe
David's been keeping all this money in
his old room like some sort of offshore
account that he couldn't fit in his
closet at his apartment there's zero
explanation for this probably because
the movie cut a whole scene out this is
Roland he got away because of drywall he
outmaneuvered me with drywall we have
his jump sites you do King how and what
does this even mean considering he can
teleport anywhere he chooses ah ah who
is this Sam Jackson rummages around this
dude's apartment finds a rare old photo
of a girl from like 10 years prior and
automatically assumes our hero is
love with her yeah he's right but that's
also kind of my point still not sure
what's worse him inexplicably calling
this guy rice ball or him recognizing
the older rice bowl yeah who cares
send it twice this is a cash-only bar in
2008 and is somehow popular with the
college kids you're asking me to go to
Rome
I mean only if you want to skip the
boring parts that worked haven't seen
each other in five years five minutes
into the reunion they're headed to Rome
also if you can instantly teleport
anywhere it must be grueling to sit
still on a 10 or more flight to Italy
that's pushing it Ann Arbor is close
enough to Detroit that it's most likely
you drove to Detroit's Airport to fly
out to New York City that process alone
is a good couple hours and Google tells
me an average flight from New York City
to Rome is over eight hours so unless
you had no layover at all there's no way
you got from Ann Arbor to Rome in ten
hours and that's not even considering
the fact that I'm assuming he hadn't
even purchased tickets yet when they
were in the bar but they still got seats
on the first flight out the director
said you're a thief and you were
terrible in Star Wars movies but the
only way people will truly know you're
an asshole is if you eat an apple I
think well duh
why didn't you think or say this before
the 10-hour trip to Rome me you don't
want to tell me everything that's fun
just hide away huh
those are the same thing an omission of
truth is still a lot you're drawing a
super fine line just so you can trick
yourself into thinking it's okay to fall
in love with that old weird kid from
high school who showed up this morning
and you flew to Rome with immediately
then how'd you get it down in the first
place methinks the movie is trying too
hard to create physical intimacy between
these two which is weird she quit her
job and left Michigan five minutes after
re meeting it I'm guessing both of these
people are already highly down too also
did they stop by our house for a sexy
dress on the way to the airport and this
is the only thing she brought that needs
to hang rookie we've seen this jerk face
three times in this movie impact to the
movie zero why is it so damn important
for David to show Millie around in the
Coliseum right here and right now
don't they have another day or two in
Rome to see this place and plus they
already does work it's done in my
opinion no one sees this got a mess
worth the risk still a huge fence behind
you where guards employees or police can
notice you and no not worth the risk
door just open - it's open now this girl
was confluent Oh globe in high school it
made a huge impression on her that's the
only reason I could think
why she'd fly to Rome spur the moment
and then do double breaking-and-entering
with this guy again no workers anywhere
in this bitch the Roman Colosseum is
easier to break into than an American
politicians email Griffon absolutely
needed to tell David about how stupid he
was being but he waited until right now
when they're about to get attacked by
Samuel Jackson's taser goons to let him
in on the fact that there are other
jumpers then oh that these dicks know
that David or Griffin we're in the
Colosseum right now we know Roland knows
that David was in Rome but Rome is a big
place hey why not teleport to the top of
the Sphinx in Egypt right now or some
super far away place as opposed to
continuing this Colosseum fight charade
people jumping and lots of running mixed
with quick edits I don't know what's
going on you don't know what's going on
let's call the whole thing off I think
that's how the song goes
also this movie really could have used a
good storyboard artist checking IMDB
Jeremy Sims er yeah that guy you still
couldn't make this work
so not once during that big action scene
and the Colosseum did Milly notice
anything that was going on she heard
commotion but decided not to check it
out those are cops dude at this point
it's easier to teleport you and Milly
far away from here and sure you'll have
to have a tough discussion with her but
at least neither of you will be arrested
Diane Lane makes a brief appearance as
David's mom somehow knew her son was
being detained at a Roman police station
and decided to take this opportunity to
basically say I know you have a lot of
questions and I'm Diane Lane get the
hell out of here David leaves this guy
on top of the Sphinx but okay he's an
Italian cop just doing his job so it's
hilarious so trust me why do you want to
trust him again because of the snow
globe I mean we have that memory then he
shows up years later and you go with him
to Rome in an instant your desire to
trust him is incongruous with what we've
been shown you should doubt this
motherfucker hard I can't get on this
flight with you Millie as far as we go
together so from your perspective i
whisked you off to Rome and if you got
arrested then broke up with you we lost
him Sir how many did you send
I told you to send everybody she said to
it be enough Wow we have the pronoun
gain going on here and we have a direct
order being challenged by some mystery
person
I'm guessing Diane Lane who previously
did not figure into any of the plot
we've seen so far including Roland's
visit to David's apartment earlier more
searching and right now if you want your
searching the grid if this movie
bothered to explain anything to me about
how these jumpers are being tracked I
might have enjoyed this movie more
instead of just fuse technobabble balls
like this and thinks it's a Bourne movie
movie shows an orgy of evidence that
David's dad is still a drunk by showing
us not one not two but three King beer
bottles lying on top of his car expertly
placed he didn't even throw one of them
to the ground did he and can I say for
the record that the midnight car repair
is probably more evidence of him being
drunk than the three beer bottles holy
the brand loyalty in this apartment is
astounding
Pepsi products galore does this asshole
work for Pepsi also he's got like a
whole six-pack of Mountain Dew next to
several empty cans of Pepsi how does his
love of Mountain Dew and Pepsi get along
because I'm telling you right here and
now it doesn't goddamn it still alive
dude last time he was here you were
livid and screaming for him to leave
what changed there's more than hundreds
more I'm tracking ten right now is this
movie gonna tell us anything about this
unexplained janitor lying handcuffed in
the corner over here
something tells me an entire scene was
cut out you really don't get it do you
pythons have been killing jumpers for
years we're back since medieval times
well how is he supposed to get it if no
one ever tells him the it kind of hard
to tell in this scene is she's upset at
the whole thing with David or that she's
flying Delta guy in a Fox movie does his
duty and watch his Fox because why the
Fox not how in the hell did David know
this dickhead was in this jail remember
he took mark into a bank vault and then
transported back to Millie's bar where
they then immediately flew to Italy so
he had no idea about marks fate at all
also what exactly does David hope to
achieve here he's basically parading
this bully guy into admitting he told
Sam Jackson about Millie but Millie is
already screwed and you already got
busted and Rome together
so how disproving it was the bully's
fault that led to all it actually helped
you right now are we supposed to believe
that modern planes drones and satellites
can't spot this in the open desert
because it feels like we are and that's
just silly goddamn this Billy Elliot
assholes jumps car lasts for ten goddamn
seconds again with the jump sights movie
suggests there are limited places these
assholes can jump to but also claims
they can jump anywhere they want and
mostly it just pisses me off I'd have
this common thing and I know where to
find rolled
dude why didn't you lead with that when
you tried to join forces with Griffon
earlier he told you I can't find rollin
I've tried and tried and tried and you
just stood there okay sure but don't
these jumps usually leave some damage
how'd he speed toward this glass without
it breaking also there in the middle of
Tokyo where we just saw the police
hustling and bustling and yet nobody saw
this it's everyone in this world muggles
also why even drive ain't geez these
guys drive this car all night or did
they actually find a hotel somewhere
it's the point of this damn Tokyo trip
anyway oops
Griffin didn't leave any kind of scar
this time I guess that was only for plot
convenience your friend came by are you
talking about black eye white hair you
just missed him my question is why
wasn't Roland or any of the paladins at
the airport waiting for that plane to
land in the first place why did he have
to resort to looking for Millie at the
bar I'm banking okay it's David's secret
such that he thinks Millie will never
want to speak to him again if she finds
out he's got a secrets bogged down a
movie like this she could've learned
about the secret in Rome and we'd have a
much better picture by bringing him down
either can follow you they have a
machine something that I could have told
you a long time ago and this movie could
have told us a long time ago but it was
considered such a surprise they held it
back until the stakes were highest also
they haven't used a machine to follow a
jumper this entire movie even though
they could certainly have used such a
machine but now all the sudden machine
this movie's got to be half on the
cutting room floor because it's got cool
that ultimately doesn't make sense
despite coming in at a studio approved
1.5 hours totally unredeemable character
somehow redeems himself at the most
climactic moment possible this is
totally against his character so I'm
calling this an about-face cliched yes
but they can still somehow shoot a cable
through the scar without it which is
some deep deep Bulls also they were
aiming for her like they somehow knew
she would be on the other side because
Roland yells yeah like that was the plan
all along
and David jumped to a whole other place
right after this one maybe put the bomb
and the save at the bank I mean he knew
Griffon would jump through a scar right
so why not do something harder to trace
I have a hard time believing they have
enough time for this world hopping this
fight one wants to save Millie and the
other wants to kill Rowland but neither
of them has time for this someone's got
some explaining to do with one of their
frequent jumping points is a fucking
kiddie pool also both these dudes to die
from this pool entry considering the
velocity they were travelling at before
the jump
oh shit right now the Griffin jump this
car at the exact angle he needed to be
going directly at David right now and
why didn't David just throw the damn
detonator in the water already man jump
five feet to the right and throw that
bitch
also that asshole had time to hijack a
fucking truck in the last location and
then drive it through this scar why in
the world would you ever jump to
Chechnya for any reason did you get
bored one day and think man I wonder
what Chechnya is like and after you
visited why would it pop into your head
as a place you'd want to go again also
that's definitely racist this dumbass
thinks rescuing mili will be this easy
it sure would have been nice to know all
the rules earlier rather than just when
the plot needed you to know these
details I think this movie is way more
x-men the last stand on the filmmakers
intent Moody goes full circle jerk and
has david transport from the water to
the port library again um wasn't she
been kissing him right before they
teleported let's pretend the protagonist
is dead for a few minutes at the for the
audience she's lying flat on her back
here and then she's upright mid-sentence
David transports this guy to the Grand
Canyon instead of 10,000 feet into the
atmosphere for a casual drop-off could
drop she with the sharks or on the moon
actually jeez you might as well have
dropped him in with the sharks because
he's supposed to get down from this he
doesn't have any climbing gear no cell
phone you left him for dead man somehow
after stranding rollin in the Grand
Canyon
David was given the address for his mom
by someone I mean what ah random Kristen
Stewart cameo I only had two choices
kill you love you so you left to protect
you again to protect you from what you
have all the power here you could have
told David about his powers and
protected him by telling him not to use
them in a stupid way how does learning
this on his own protect him any better
than the care you could have provided
with the knowledge you possess again I
did it to protect you cliche is total
bullshit it shouldn't even be a cliche
so I'm a jumper you're a paladin
well now I'm giving you a head start son
look lady either you want him to live or
you want to do your job this middle
ground bull will not fly with me also if
you were gonna turn him in or kill him
you'd have done it back when he was five
and you discovered his abilities so NP
threat is empty total nonsense and
anyway isn't it funny how this
connection that Roland made earlier
didn't even factor into this movie he
knows Mary is David's mom yet nothing
came of it other than a hunt isn't that
weird
dummy dummy jump in and boys I de sant
ever since cinemasins began the most
requested thing has been TV since and
now it's a reality click the link in the
description below to check it out
and now the audio outtakes I will be the
most powerful Jedi ever I promise you I
want everybody up and running give me
the damn minute David
once I was a normal person a chump just
like you I'm an average nobody get to
live the rest of my life like a schnook
I can see our hotel from here I noticed
you have three X's tattooed on the back
of your neck I think that's rather
appropriate since you looking at three
strikes
can you believe dat ten hours ago we
were in Ann Arbor you know what I can't
believe I can't believe tomorrow's
Thursday
[Applause]
yes mr. talking huh am i gained the
message earlier you were the chosen one
if we say that you the stylist is not
join them